foreign
so we got an article here
um that's written using the research
from multiple doctors and uh it is
detailing for specific things that
happen to you while you're dying whoa
It's released but you release GHB or
something don't you lose like a little
bit of weight and they say that that's
your soul leaving but some people say
that's just you farting and peeing is
that true that you release your bowels
dude yeah you do so that's in one but
they don't got one poop they don't guys
so like something it's weird because a
lot of people who have died and then
were revived you know like where they
were dead from like oh man I [__] my
pants I love those stories yeah they all
have like different experiences because
you you do go into a state kind of a DMT
State yeah where your brain's trying to
preserve like uh I guess like the
suffering wow so that you don't really
you have a as peaceful as a death as you
could possibly have so you you might see
[__] random [__] but um that's crazy
as far as the the confirmed things that
everyone will have these are the four
things so
um one thing is shallow breathing
um like when you're being watched as
you're like going That's How medical
professionals know that oh they're going
is that your breathing gets really
shallow and uh you lose control of your
mouth and throat so your breathing
becomes fully controlled by just your
contractions here which means that you
could start breathing like
like and that's why that that thing is a
thing yeah because you can't control the
breathing from here anymore so it's just
yeah you could have like kind of like a
slobbery breathing or oh it's getting
too real early that's yeah yeah so you
but then you could still be breathing
but it's no longer it's involuntary at
that point you're not conscious of doing
it so you're a zombie that's pretty good
yeah it's like what do you mean when
you're sleeping like it's just happening
yeah yeah exactly that's an autopilot
sleep apnea and you breathe more slowly
and more shallow and that's how they uh
when they're monitoring you they call it
like death's door
dang so like before you die people are
already like oh this person's gonna die
yeah because uh yeah your breathing gets
shallow and you it's like it looks
different because like when nor your
normal breathing
usually it's not that ugly
your mom
you're gonna take that dude yeah you
like that got it from you
it's all good these feelings are really
hurt we can move on I and so another
thing is is uh this is very vague but
it's like a confirmed thing it you
really do kind of fall asleep like the
same uh the same like melatonin dude
yeah there's like something with that
where you actually do go to sleep in a
way that's peaceful but it's in a way
that uh you know when you're asleep
sometimes you can uh kind of
you can kind of hear stuff like you
you're conscious yeah yeah yeah so they
were saying that like even though
um you're it looks like you it looks
like you're actually going like if
you're going you know an extra dying
guy's ear he's still gonna like do this
but it's not a true
um response response yeah it's like an
auto response in a way so you're saying
all those moments in movies and stuff
were like they're right there they just
got shot and then they're like it's
getting cold and then that kind of
closer up cold is good like that but
really they're still kind of like they
just fell asleep right they're about to
die yeah right they sleep first and then
die and there's um there's an account
from a person who was getting what's
called an angiogram I'm not sure what
that is but basically
um they were Wide Awake
watching the screen but they weren't
fully uh like they couldn't move or
something and then um they noticed that
the the machine started beeping all the
monitors were going off and then all the
people started packing like a medical
staff that was that person dying and
they were just like looking at it like
what the [__]
and she was awake yeah awake yeah
we're going so everyone was like oh [__]
but not like do all this stuff and they
all started like to move as a unit she
was awake but she could see it yeah oh
it was [__] crazy yeah and then she
said that that she started to fade and
everything got foggy and then the next
thing she knows she's uh she's awake
again in a different uh position and she
just hears them say oh we got her back
hello so she was dying yeah she was
absolutely dying [__] another thing um
the third is brain activity uh it lights
up doesn't it
yeah there's like weird synapses and
like weird things that are going on
um and it is that same thing of like how
your brain responds to different stimuli
by itself
um not necessarily that you are
receiving that information but it's just
making note of things it's like a weird
uh situation where
um
even though you're talking to a person
that's dying they're hearing it but
they're not necessarily processing it
like they're not aware of it yeah it's
like a different it's a total different
uh brain response than what you would do
when you're alive and well yeah yeah
crazy and then the uh the fourth one is
like people kind of describe like a lot
of people say the same thing where it
feels like they're you know that cliche
of like oh there's a light at the end
and I feel like I'm walking to it that's
a super common like most people who have
died and came back to life say that same
thing yeah wow it's it's insane it's a
very high amount yeah yeah I like
listening to stories on YouTube but
people that died and came back and it's
very similar a lot of stuff is like oh
it's online and I kept going to the line
and on the other side then it's a
different story every single time but it
sounds like DMT trips yeah yeah there
was a lie there's a tunnel and then
Jesus was there or like other people
would be like there was a lie and on the
other end it was my family or like
whatever and there's like there's also
some weird cases two of people being
able to see
uh to see the room from another angle
like astral production like astral
projection it's like a thing where they
like were able to describe people that
were around their body that they didn't
know were there prior whoa and then when
they came back they're like
they look and that person's there like
oh I didn't know you were here like like
a relative or something that didn't want
to watch is that they're like Soul
leaving their body and they can see in
the corner I don't know yeah damn that's
great it's hard to say that it's like
they can't reaction yeah but just um and
the crazy thing is too is that sometimes
they think they think they're responding
to the things you're saying to them but
they're not like if you're like no come
back well it's like in their mind in
their dying mind they could be saying
I'm here I'm fine don't worry about it
it's okay yeah and they come back to
life and they're like why didn't you
hear I was telling you that I was fine
well you're like you weren't even
talking like they're like you were just
going like it's really crazy I was
trying to tell you I told you I was okay
sleep paralysis experience like that
where I was in my bed and I woke up and
then I was like oh let me check my phone
you know pick it up go like this and
then my all my eyes see is nothing and
I'm like wait I felt my arm go to my
phone put it in front of my face but
then when my eyes was watching it
nothing was there and then I was like I
woke up I was like oh [__] I was
sleeping but then I felt myself seeing
everything and doing everything up until
the point where I'm like how come I
don't see my phone in my face didn't
recognize it huh face ID yeah something
like that because it like I was doing
the Motions I would normally do in my
head but then when I woke up I was like
oh [__] I actually wasn't doing anything
I was just laying there
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's bad
yeah so when I see nothing so even
though there's no there's absolutely no
way to prove like when someone comes out
of that state without anything was real
or really happening they were really
seeing it these are just the most things
that tend to cross and be in common with
like different situations yeah trip
funny oh man I know man I absolutely
think the soul is real yeah of course
what's your evidence dude there's no
evidence it's like how come it only
happens the DMT stuff only happens when
you're born when you're dreaming and
when you sleep I think it happens when
you're born is because the moment the
baby is about to come out the [__]
soul comes in and that pushes the DMT oh
so you don't think fetuses have a soul
uh I don't I don't know about that
interesting take well you won't know
until they can start talking and [__]
you know what I mean because I don't
even know
if they have a soul it is interesting
what makes living things living yeah
because you kind of think of like things
that are able to like move and be
animated have a motor right like a like
a car if without the engine the car's
not gonna move so right now we're living
so we can move but what is the engine no
no we're the engine is the driver who's
driving it that's the Consciousness no
no we're the driver but it's the
Consciousness who's the Consciousness
who is the conscious so who's the brain
and the person that's controlling the
car yeah Ricky Bobby so that's the
that's what the soul would consider be
considered because you could like you
were saying like oh yeah I could hear
but I'm not aware of it right you know
what I mean like so like even for like a
lizard right like between a live lizard
and a dead lizard anatomically you cut
it apart it's the same lizard yeah but
what brings the life in what's moving it
that's the thing exactly who turned on
the key to the ignition yeah yeah but
maybe it's something that you you can't
really measure in this world like
physically you know that's the thing
yeah yeah
you're never going to find it get back
to the thing so like you know even when
you dream why do you release DMT when
you dream right I think it's because
um you're trying to get a good trip your
soul is like actually leaving your body
and going to a dream world so that's why
you get DMT release and so even when you
die your soul is actually leaving your
body so that also releases the DMT you
know what I mean so you think when
you're sleeping your soul is leaving
your body yeah every time no matter what
people astral project when they sleep
and they can see themselves sleep but
what if you get woken up because
somebody's alarm went off and you didn't
even set up alarm but somebody in the
room decided to [__] put up a six
o'clock alarm on and you wake up and
rushes back
some degree when you're dreaming it's
still Tethered to you like your body
like it snaps back like a grapevine yeah
but then when you when you're dead
there's nothing to tether back to so
you're just gone in the spirit world
yeah what do you say Joe I think that it
has to be a life is like a chain of UN
interrupted like
like sis like like sequences right so
like let's say like Mom and Dad right
pop uh they have a sexy time right and
then life is created between the sperm
and then the egg and then it's like it's
like it's like boiling right so that's
already like going it's going it's like
an energy so it's not dead they're
they're [__] building it baby comes
out right human comes out right so then
this life force becomes ready to mate
and then another one comes right so it's
perpetually
going there's no like dead thing that
becomes alive it's just constantly alive
through a connection of passing the
Baton so then that's I I don't know if
like um
you know some people might not believe
that life starts at
the the Single Cell organ or whatever
like amoeba yeah but then for me that's
already an energy source that's
compacted into a small like piece a sale
like a sperm and then you got the
[__] egg right and they're living
things and then it created a combination
to create the the full life form so it's
always life there's it's just living so
I don't know if if there's a concept of
um something being dead and then it
becomes alive the physical body suddenly
like is like turned on yeah so then when
I think about the concept of life then
it's like
then it's been an energy that's been an
organism that's being either split or
transferred and then like the energy is
constantly going until its end of its
time whether by accident or because of
old like they they use this organism too
much to the point where now it's like
you can't use it no more so then it's
like boom it's gone but then at that
idea of a soul is maybe that is what you
need
for this like life form to take
um character or take like yes you know
what I mean like like it's not just a
robot like it has now characteristics or
something that moves it forward but you
know and desire or something like that
with the idea of that energy like
getting dispersed and then it dies off
but it continues multiplying but like is
it energy like just transferred it's not
completely destroyed it's never created
and it's actually never it's just
transition so so the concept of after
you die something gets transferred right
oh yeah like where does it go in the
great words of uh nacho beneath the man
we find
a nucleus
[Music]
foreign